♪ ♪
>> Sean: A BOMBSHELL REPORT
ABOUT THE DEEP STATE, JOHN
SOLOMON, LISTEN TO THIS.
EXPLOSIVE STORY FROM THE HILL
TONIGHT, A CONVENIENT OMISSION,
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ADVISOR DENIED
COLLUSION TO FBI SOURCE EARLY
ON.
NOW, IT IS ABOUT THE FBI
IGNORING EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE IN
THEIR FISA WARRANT APPLICATIONS.
JOHN SOLOMON JOINS US COME ALONG
WITH FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN AIDE
GEORGE POPPEL LAPIDUS, HIS WIFE
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR H
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR S
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR D
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR F
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR N
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR E
SIMONA, WHO FOUGHT SO HARD FOR .
JOHN, I WILL LET YOU IT DOWN.
>> IT IS VERY SIMPLE.
REMEMBER, THE FBI OPENED UP THE
ENTIRE TRUMP COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION ON THE SUSPICION
THAT GEORGE HAD SOME COLLUSION
GOING ON BEHIND THE SCENES WITH
THE RUSSIANS, SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAILS AND THE HACKING.
IT JUST A FEW WEEKS AFTER THE
OPEN THAT INVESTIGATION, GEORGE
HAS A CONVERSATION WITH AN FBI
INFORMANT, A PROFESSOR NAMED
HELPER, IN LONDON, AND HE TELLS
HIM WE WEREN'T COLLUDING, I
WASN'T INTERESTED INCLUDING WITH
THE RUSSIANS.
IT WOULD BE TREASON, WE DIDN'T
DO IT.
THE FBI HAS THAT IN ITS
POSSESSION.
ITS OBLIGATION IS TO SHUTDOWN
THE INVESTIGATION OR FIND OTHER
EVIDENCE, WHAT DO THEY DO?
THEY DON'T TELL THE COURT, LEAVE
IT OUT OF THE FISA APPLICATION,
AND GIVE IT TO THE STEELE
DOSSIER, WHICH ARE FAR LESS
CREDIBLE THAN THE ORIGINAL
APPLICATION ABOUT GEORGE.
IT IS REALLY EVIDENCE OF
INNOCENCE.
WITHHELD FROM THE COURT, WITH
HELP FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: DON'T FORGET, FRAUD
WAS COMMITTED ON THE FISA COURT,
FOUR TIMES, BECAUSE THEY
PURPOSELY WITHHELD WHERE THE
INFORMATION CAME FROM, BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY.
AND THEY WITHHELD FROM THE COURT
THE BULK OF EVIDENCE, THE
UNVERIFIED, UNCORROBORATED
DOSSIER.
SIMONA, YOU WENT TO BAT FOR YOUR
HUSBAND WHEN HE COULDN'T SPEAK
FOR HIMSELF.
I HATE -- REMEMBER, LISA PAGE
SAYS THERE IS NO EVIDENCE.
NINE MONTHS, THAT IS WHEN THEY
STARTED THEIR LEAK STRATEGY,
INSURANCE POLICY.
REMEMBER STRZOK SAID -- EVEN
THEY SAID IT, BUT THEY LIE ABOUT
HIM.
>> THAT IS WHAT I TRY TO STRESS,
THEY NUMBER ONE, I KNOW THE
BACKGROUND.
>> Sean: PEOPLE WRITE THAT ALL
THE TIME.
>> ANYWAY, I INSISTED THERE WERE
SO MANY EXCULPATORY EVIDENCES,
AND THAT IS WHY YOU -- REALLY
WISH THAT WE COULD COME OUT,
BECAUSE I KNOW THE SENTENCE
HAS BEEN FAIR, DOESN'T DESERVE.
>> Sean: GEORGE, I WOULD SAY,
DON'T OPEN BECAUSE IN TWO
WEEKS -- ANYONE CAN SUCK UP TWO
WEEKS OF THEIR LIFE, AND I
WOULDN'T WANT YOU TO OPEN
YOURSELF UP TO SOMETHING
FURTHER.
SO YOU ARE IN A TOUGH SPOT.
BUT WHAT JOHN IS REPORTING IS
TRUE, ANYTHING YOU CAN ADD?
>> ALL I CAN ADD ABOUT THIS IS
THAT JOHN IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I HAVE NO RUSSIA CONTACTS
WHATSOEVER.
AFTER JOHN'S EXCELLENT REPORTING
AND BE RESEARCHING MY -- CERTAIN
PEOPLE IN OUR INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY KNEW IT THE WHOLE TIME
THAT THESE PEOPLE THAT I
ENCOUNTERED WERE ACTUALLY
WESTERN INTELLIGENCE, NOT
RUSSIAN CARED ONE OF MY
EARTH 100 HIM I GETTING IN
TROUBLE FOR?
I TOLD THIS PERSON, STAY AWAY
FROM ME.
>> Sean: JOHN, WHERE DO WE GO
WITH THIS?
>> SEAN, I HAVE TO TELL YOU
TONIGHT, THE SPIN COMING OUT OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
ABSOLUTELY AMAZING, I WOULD CALL
IT UN-AMERICAN.
PEOPLE TELLING ME THEY DON'T
THINK THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAD
AN OBLIGATION TO TELL THE COURTS
ABOUT EXCULPATORY INFORMATION.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A SECOND.
IN THE FISA COURT, WHERE THE
ACCUSED SOMEONE LIKE GEORGE,
DOESN'T HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE,
IT IS ALL IN SECRET, CAN YOU
IMAGINE THAT SENTIMENT BEING
SHARED WITH CONGRESS, THE JUDGES
ON THE FISA COURT, I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE HOW LONG THAT LASTS.
>> Sean: HOW DO YOU DO AFTER
THIS?
>> LOOKING TO START A FAMILY.
>> Sean: GO AFTER PEOPLE THAT
I MISTREATED YOU?
>> ANYBODY THAT HAS MISTREATED
ME I'M GOING AFTER.